Welcome back everyone this is my full venom
let there be carnage movie breakdown and Easter
eggs for the entire movie.
Hopefully you've had a chance to see it.
There's a bunch of Easter eggs and references
obviously the post credit scene is really
huge deal everything sort of connecting into
the larger marvel universe is a lot of stuff
to talk about.
So if you're brand-new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos is
a good time to be a big Spider-Man fan because
of Spider-Man No Way Home coming out right
after this we also the morbius movie coming
in Spider-Man into the spider verse two also
coming out next year.
Careful for spoilers for the movie.
If you have not seen it yet.
I know there's like a weird release thing
going on with some countries not getting the
movie for a little while, so just blanket
spoiler warning.
But the movie title.
Let there be carnage in the plot are loosely
based on Spider-Man maximum carnage combined
with carnage his origin story from the comics
and Cletus Kasady's origin story and just
based on the timeline of the post credit scene
with him being teleported to the main MCU
earth and watching the scene of J Jonah Jameson
Tom Holland's Spider-Man it seems like most
of this movie takes place just a little while
before the events of Spider-Man No Way Home
and even of the biggest Easter eggs in the
post credit scene are obviously meant to cross
venom over with Tom Holland's Spider-Man inside
the MCU.
Like bringing venom into the MCU.
There were a lot a lot of Tobey Maguire Spider-Man,
Easter eggs during this and Andrew Garfield
amazing Spider-Man, Easter eggs the opening
scene at St. Estes orphanage is a slight change
to Cletus Kasady's origins from the comics
in the whole story about him pushing his grandmother
down the stairs electrocuting his mother killing
his father.
That's all accurate to the comic book story
later he sort of references that yelling Eddie
Brock you didn't tell everyone how I was abused
in that's the reason why killed my family.
The one major change that they made was giving
him more of the back story with his girlfriend
shriek who is from the maximum carnage storyline,
but during that storyline, they only formed
a relationship after they've both been sent
to Ravencroft.
So even though Raven cropped is a big part
of the movie in the comics Cletus me shriek
for the first time.
When they're at Ravencroft together as adults
most of their early relationship back story
is just a set up the big twists with the wedding
the cortical game of thrones red wedding is
they call it later in the movie.
I was surprised to hear them make that game
of thrones reference shriek is canonically
a mutant in the movie, they change her power
shift a little bit like kind of deep powder
she does have that sonic scream ability that
you see during the movie.
But she can also fly and she has the ability
to see in the people's minds and bring out
their inner darkness another all kinds of
questions about what happened at the end of
the movie between her and Patrick Mulligan
after his fight with her, because you see
his eyes glowing blue like shriek size did
during the movie in the comics, Patrick Mulligan
becomes the host of toxin the symbiote offspring
of carnage, so I'll explain what happened
to him.
When we get to that part of the movie.
The whole intro scene here is also meant to
explain Patrick Mulligan's history was shriek
and how she got sent to Ravencroft they ready
plan to send her to Ravencroft when she was
younger and Patrick Mulligan is just one of
the police guarding her escort.
She winds up damaging his hearing trying to
escape.
He shoots her thinking that he killed her
this whole time, but because there experimenting
on mutants in this version of the Ravencroft
Institute in the venom movie, they erased
all records of her existence.
So Patrick Mulligan just thinks that she's
dead.
This whole time.
Ravencroft is a big deal.
It was featured heavily during amazing Spider-Man
two in the Andrew Garfield movies.
It was the facility where they were keeping
Harry Osborne Green goblin and in the comics,
is also really big deal is used as a mental
asylum sort of catchall/experiment lab for
insane people was superpowers.
Like I said during the maximum carnage storyline
carnage had been sent there along with shriek.
But then they jump to present day and Ravencroft
to show you what's been happening was shriek
this whole time.
Even though you don't see them experimenting
on her that's kind of what's going on with
the other inmates.
They imply that this is a place with experiments
on mutants.
But then Cletus Kasady engineers this plan
to communicate was shriek just believing somehow
that she still alive out there somewhere Cletus
then tries to turn this into a bigger thing
manipulating Eddie Brock into writing more
messages for him into the headlines in exchange
for information about where to find the rest
of the bodies that he never copped to the
way they explain Patrick Mulligan in present
day, is that he has this beef with Eddie because
Eddie's been a reporter for a long time he'd
fallen from grace before the events of the
first venom movie.
Like when that movie is taking place, he winds
up messing up his whole career his relationship
with and weighing so it's imply that he has
history with Patrick Mulligan as a reporter
he probably threw him under the bus a couple
times during previous cases in that's why
Mulligan hates him so much the movie version
of Eddie is kind of a dirt bag.
Just like comic book Eddie Brock later Eddie
also winds up giving Mulligan the finger just
making their relationship even more contentious
when the symbiote memorizes all the Cletus's
wall drawings in his cell the first time he
visits him and uses them to decode the location
of the bodies.
So the Eddie no longer needs to publish Cletus
messages Pissing up both Cletus Kasady and
Mulligan because he agreed to share any evidence
that he got with Mulligan and he just winds
up finding the bodies and taking credit for
which the symbiote also gets pissed off about
later to wait a minute I was the one.
The decoded all those messages I did the detective
work again.
Like I said Eddie kind of acts like a dirt
bag for the lease of first big part of the
movie, but because they find all of Cletus
his body so quickly the authorities reinstate
the death penalty in California just for Kasady
and he said to be executed shortly thereafter
while this is all playing out this big montage
the venom symbiote also has it out with Eddie
over him not letting him eat real human brains
the way they explain is the symbiote see the
special chemical that brains excrete and they
can only get it in its purest source from
human brains.
So he's reduce the symbiote to eating chicken
brains which don't provide the level of nutrition
that it actually needs to survive the also
play this up for a couple jokes to because
the symbiote has been keeping a couple of
live chickens as pets name Sonny and Cher
in if you don't know real world history Sonny
and Cher about up having this very famous
split divorce.
Which sort of foreshadows the split that venom
and Eddie have later in the movie, but because
that he takes credit for finding the bodies
his career gets back on track and he starts
publishing more recent work in the daily bugle
obviously big Spider-Man, Easter egg.
But you notice the logo from this daily bugle
is the logo from the Tobey Maguire Spider-Man
movies, so cool Spider-Man Easter egg, but
also kind of meant to foreshadow the post
credit scene with MCU J Jonah Jameson and
his version of the daily bugle when he sentenced
to die Cletus winds up writing another handwritten
note inviting Eddie to his execution just
to go him there so we can try to stick it
to him one last time he makes all these references
to superheroes and people rescuing other people
an origin stories as he smashes a spider that
crawls up on the table.
Another big Spider-Man, Easter egg he's actually
using his own blood in this pen to write the
note.
That's why the ink is red is also meant to
be foreshadowing for him getting the carnage
symbiote it being a red one.
The way they change the carnage origin story
from the comics is one real major change Cletus
winds up goading the symbiote into lashing
out at it literally in then while they're
fighting bites Eddie ingesting some of his
symbiote infuse blood in that's how they get
the carnage symbiote I guess you could also
look at this is a funny wink at a reverse
Spider-Man character origin story.
Like Spider-Man got bitten by a radioactive
spider and gets all of his powers, but in
this situation you have Cletus Kasady biting
a Spider-Man character.
Like a person biting a Spider-Man character
and getting their powers that way if you remember
Spider-Man into the spider verse.
There was also a funny joke about the Peter
Parker character during that he was a regular
spider, who been a radioactive pig in became
spider ham that way later in the movie, carnage
calls venom dad, so there's a little handwaving
as to how symbiote reproduction works they
reproduce asexually, but is their way of adapting
the comic book origin story in that version
Eddie was cellmates with Cletus in the venom
symbiote busted Eddie out of prison while
doing so reproduced in the offspring just
bonded with the nearest person who happened
to be Cletus Kasady usually with each new
generation of symbiote, the offspring become
more powerful.
That's why toxin the offspring of carnage
is supposed to be even more powerful than
carnage later during the final battle.
They also clarifies some of the symbiote power
scaling reads he carnage quote unquote reload
like he literally says time to reload and
eats another person, allowing himself to become
even more powerful even larger.
I know this also kind of raises the question
if venom winds up eating carnage and Cletus
at the end of the movie does that give him
a huge power upgrade in the answer is yes
at least a temporary big power boost.
I did not catch who did the voice of carnage
is that she Tom Hardy who does the voice of
the venom symbiote voice just process it a
whole bunch.
But the carnage voice did not sound like Woody
Harrelson it all one of the other weird changes
to the carnage symbiote abilities most of
them are the comic book ability just forming
Hardage weapons and projectiles.
But somehow the carnage symbiote knows how
to hack computers I know exactly what's going
on with that maybe it got it through its hive
knowledge in connection to the venom symbiote
because the venom symbiote has been using
computers through Eddie for a long time now.
But apparently the symbiote's are now full
blown computer hackers, carnage, winds up
striking a deal with Cletus to help break
shriek at of Ravencroft in exchange for Cletus
helping it kill the venom symbiote claiming
that that will make them more powerful.
This is in a really huge thing in the comics,
the carnage symbiote usually does want to
kill it's father venom in its offspring toxin,
but only because their threats not for any
other weird reason I think in the movie.
There's this whole idea that carnage would
truly become free and also get the added power
boost the comes from consuming another symbiote.
Like, there's this big theme about freedom
to live your life on your own terms with Eddie
in venom having to constantly hide themselves
for fear being arrested they explained the
FBI is still investigating what happened during
the events of the first venom movie with the
lie foundation and all the missing bodies
around Eddie's apartment Mulligan makes the
connection to Eddie Brock being around all
these crime scenes and things that he has
something to do with it.
And that's why they want to arrest him later
in obviously after the events of the big final
battle.
It only helps reinforce that idea with Mulligan
watching this all play out learning about
the symbiote's for real, so Eddie Brock ever
comes back to his original universe, he'd
still be a wanted criminal so around the time
Cletus becomes carnage Eddie in venom have
their breakup so to speak.
They have a bit of a SyQuest where the symbiote
bonds with a whole bunch of other people random
hosting goes this underground club ranting
about his terrible relationship with Eddie.
But ultimately realizing that he needs them
crawling back to Mrs. Chen several times during
their fights.
The venom symbiote also calls itself the lethal
protector from the venom comic book story,
the Lisa protector storyline was also the
basis of the plot of the first movie.
The whole thing with Mrs. Chen and her store
that carries over from the ending of the first
movie is that now they explained she knows
all about venom and struck a deal with Eddie
for their protection in exchange she supplies
them with a steady supply of chocolate this
laced with the same chemical found in human
brains that the symbiote needs to survive
later when the symbiote almost dies from malnourishment
in all the Rando bodies Mrs. Chen becomes
his temporary host until they can get it to
bond with Eddie again.
They mostly played for laughs in the Senate
that whole and weighing lady venom twists.
The whole lady venom scene during the movie
is very similar to the events of the first
movie where she winds a bonding with the symbiote
to save Eddie Brock this time saving him from
the police station.
This also this funny moment after the symbiote
goes back to Eddie where she's like let's
never do that again except maybe let's do
that again because that was really fun.
So they that's the idea that when they do
venom three and they bring and weighing back
the also do more lady venom during that film,
you also notice inside Mrs. Chen store.
There's a big Stanley cameo scene Easter egg
with a comic book with his face on the cover
that reads the amazing career of Stanley which
is a reference to the Spider-Man comics and
more foreshadowing for the big Spider-Man
twist in the post credit scene carnage rescuing
shriek from Ravencroft and breaking out is
meant to be a version of the story from maximum
carnage they wind up going back to St. Estes
to burn it down and then get married at a
nearby church cathedral also using the wedding
as a way of getting rid of the rest of their
loose ends shriek getting revenge on Mulligan
for trying to kill her Cletus making good
on his end of the bargain with carnage helping
him kill venom in this is where they make
their big game of thrones reference, calling
it a red wedding it's very on the nose kind
of referenced way they play it carnage is
also a red symbiote.
So I think they were trying to make that connection
to tell Cletus the Lannister send their regards
so they wind of capturing and weighing in
Mulligan separately and then presenting them
to each other as wedding gifts the ceremony
also forming a priest to perform the ceremony
the big church battle with the bell is also
meant to be a reference back to the original
venom origin story from the comics, wherein
Peter Parker Spider-Man goes to a church using
the bells to get rid of the symbiote it bonds
with Eddie Brock for the first time they did
this during a version of Tobey Maguire Spider-Man
three movie.
This also really cool connection to that version
of venom in the post credit scene with the
multiverse hive mind that the symbiote tab.
So we'll talk about that in a second to during
their fight carnage literally says the phrase
let there be carnage.
The other big change here during the final
boss fight to the carnage character is the
way he Cletus are bonded is not quite the
same as comic book carnage in the movie, they
go the opposite direction with that with carnage
hating Cletus his now wife shriek because
of her sonic powers affecting it.
The carnage symbiote keeps trying to kill
shriek Cletus fighting it from inside their
bond trying to stop it Eddie finally use the
church bells and shriek to separate carnage
from Cletus in then eat the carnage symbiote.
After which venom eats Cletus right before
this happens though shriek seemingly kills
Mulligan and it seems like he comes back to
life.
The way they play it the same way the Cletus
briefly died.
Like his heart stopped until the carnage symbiote
emerge from his body and saved him.
But when Mulligan comes back to consciousness.
His eyes are glowing blue and he's screaming
about monsters.
So another all kinds of questions about this.
Like to carnage leave a piece of itself behind
to bond with him and become toxin from the
comics, what I think they're trying to imply
here is that shriek somehow through her powers
activated a mutation in Mulligan and that's
the reason why his eyes were glowing the same
color is shriek size during the movie.
And they'll just address it in future sequels
are spinoffs him yelling about monsters.
I think is meant to provide some connection
to the morbius movie, so I think we'll get
some more context for this mutation with Mulligan
after that movie comes out early next year.
It's coming out in January's who want to wait
that long also with toxin the whole post credit
scene telenovela moment implies that venom
could get pregnant again and we could see
a version of toxin in the future as venom
takes off to avoid being arrested.
They have a conversation about Sancho Panza
and Don Quixote using their relationship in
the Don Quixote story is a metaphor for Eddie
Brock and venom's relationship saying that
they're good together.
Even though it's really crazy relationship
also paying off venom's one wish from earlier
in the movie to feel sand between his toes
and wind in its ear even though the symbiote
don't have hair they can make a joke about
that Eddie takes into a beach in the beach
is meant to be the same location where their
hotel room is in the post credit scene.
I boarded than a full video for the post credit
scene in all the Easter eggs and references
while link at the end of this and down the
description.
But during that the symbiote explains that
it has 80 billion ly of hive mind knowledge
across the multiverse.
So the race of the symbiote's the Klyntar
are seemingly connected across the multiverse
and really deep way them when the symbiote
starts to show him these memories there seemingly
teleported to the main MCU universe.
But the symbiote says I didn't do this and
Eddie said I had nothing to do this either
there's this weird glitching effect that looks
exactly like the same glitching effect from
Spider-Man into the spider verse when characters
are traveling between universes their hotel
room changes into a much nicer version of
itself with all towels shaped like ducks all
around them and instead of the telenovela
on the TV it's a broadcast of MCU J Jonah
Jameson yelling about Tom Holland's Spider-Man
then venom gets up, licks the TV and says
that guy as if it recognizes him to one of
the early theories is the reason why it recognizes
that guy is because the hive knowledge connecting
it to the version of the venom symbiote from
Tobey Maguire Spider-Man three who fought
Peter Parker Spider-Man in that movie in that's
how he knows who Peter Parker Spider-Man is
even though he looks different he's like oh
yeah that guy.
But like I said based on what's going on in
this broadcast with him yelling about Spider-Man
in the timeline of the Spider-Man No Way Home
trailer.
I think most of this post credit scene happens
before they conduct the spell and then being
transported to the other Earth has something
to do with what Dr. strange is doing blending
different realities with the spell to make
people forget about Spider-Man in the main
MCU universe.
This doesn't mean that venom is going to be
a huge character during Spider-Man No Way
Home.
But I do expect at least some kind of reference
to him or post credit scene from their side
of things.
Just to acknowledge what just happened.
The way the Tom Hardy in the Sony people have
talked about the Spider-Man venom crossover
movie now.
Because obviously this is what this is teasing
them crossing over.
They made it sound like that movie will be
kind of a spinoff, like it won't be Spider-Man
for in it won't be venom three's will do more
Spider-Man venom crossover videos in the next
week or so talking about that.
He spotted any really huge Easter eggs during
the movie that I didn't talk about during
the video just right them blown the comments
my full what if episode nine finale video
will post next Wednesday just like normal
and I'll be doing episode for the Hawkeye
series and I'll be doing more Spider-Man No
Way Home videos soon to will get another trailer.
Pretty soon everyone click here for my full
venom let there be carnage post credit scene
video and click here for my marvel what if
episode nine finale trailer video you so much
for watching everyone stay safe and I'll see
you in the next one!